los bosques de la amazonía brasileña
están cada vez más mermados la mayor
selva tropical del mundo se enfrenta a
un aumento en su nivel de deforestación
año tras año un problema que los
especialistas dicen sólo se puede
solventar desde el gobierno
desafortunadamente lo que vemos los
datos oficiales presentan mes a postones
año a post año desde 2016 una
intensificación de la deforestación y
eso no se va a frenar sino la decisión
política no se convierta en acción
concreta los indicadores de pérdida de
suelo siguen subiendo en abril de 2021
la deforestación aumentó un 42 8%
respecto al mismo período del año
anterior algo que pone en peligro a la
fauna y flora autóctonas y también a las
comunidades indígenas asentadas en la
zona junto al cambio climático la
minería y la tala de madera ilegal son
las principales amenazas para la
preservación de la amazonía unas
prácticas que el gobierno no
a regular debido al difícil acceso que
tienen muchas localizaciones de la
floresta brasileña lo que pasa es que
simbólicamente han disminuido la
autoridad de los fiscales la capacidad
de llegar a áreas remotas con
equipamientos adecuados como coches
adecuados como incluso armamentos o
tractores para impedir la acción de la
minería ilegal cuando llegó al poder en
2019 bolsonaro tildó a las
organizaciones ambientales de cáncer no
obstante en abril se comprometió a
acabar con la deforestación ilegal para
el 2030 pero la presencia militar en la
zona no ha impedido el aumento de la
deforestación desde que inició su
mandato además brasil ha registrado las
peores cifras de devastación amazónica
de su historia según un estudio de la
revista 'nature en la última década el
amazonas' emitió un más dióxido de
carbono del que absorbió rompiendo su
equilibrio tradicional